ça y est il est arrivé le vaccin a
commencé à être administré en france
mais plus la période de vaccination
approche et plus la défiance monte au
sein de la population clairement le
vaccin moi personnellement je ne suis
pas prête encore pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de recul
sur
sur la le vaccin
et ce qui peut arriver après dans une
dernière étude de santé publique france
on apprend que seuls 40% des français
souhaitent se faire vacciner contre 53%
un mois auparavant une des grandes
raisons de cette défiance est la crainte
d'effets secondaires
alors quels sont ils et sont ils
dangereux on a analysé ça pour factures
[Musique]
pour commencer regardons de plus près le
vaccin pfizer les phases ii et iii des
tests ont été réalisés sur plus de
quarante trois mille personnes réparties
en deux groupes de manière aléatoire
certains ont reçu le vaccin et d'autre
un placebo mais ni les volontaires ni
les médecins ne savaient qui le recevait
de cette façon on limite les influence
sur les résultats et on peut comparer
les deux groupes
alors at-on constaté des effets
secondaires eh bien oui plusieurs
regards dont l'étude de l'aef dié
l'agencé américaine du médicament
on y retrouve des douleurs locales ou
musculaires de la fièvre de la fatigue
des maux de tête des frissons ou encore
médias ils sont assez courants mais
faut-il s'en inquiéter
les effets secondaires sont assez
fréquents mineurs ils sont assez
fréquents il ya des chips variable
peut-être 20% pour tromper on stimule
l'immunité et donc il y a des réactions
inflammatoires locales à la stimulation
mobilité donc c'est benaïssa disparaît
en quelques heures
outre ses effets si il y en a eu le plus
sérieux liés à ce vaccin chez trois
patients une blessure à l'épaule une
arythmies ventriculaires chez une
personne déjà cardiaque et une
apparition de gand millions mais sortons
de cette étude
depuis le début des vaccinations on a pu
constater des cas de réactions
allergiques sévères au vaccin de pfizer
comme en alaska ou au royaume uni l'
agence européenne du médicament a
d'ailleurs interdit aux personnes
allergiques de se faire vacciner
personnellement je préconise que ce soit
systématiquement le médecin généraliste
qui fasse la vaccination et et qu'ils
puissent éventuellement est à berry aux
contre-indications parce que il y a
probablement un certain nombre de contre
indication chez certaines personnes
passons en vaccins du laboratoire
moderna même procédure que pour le bac 5
riders et efficace à 94 5 % les mêmes
effets secondaires mineurs sont
constatés les plus récurrents sont des
douleurs locales qui peuvent durer deux
à trois jours des effets secondaires
sérieux reliés à ce vaccin ont aussi
étaient détectés dont deux inflammation
du visage et un cas de vomissement un
contrôle lien de causalité difficile
établir par exemple dans modern day a eu
des pales qui passionne qui survient
après des infections virales mais il y
en a eu aussi dans le groupe placebo
donc on va avoir à faire face à
l'apparition entraîné de maladies rares
si on vaccine de genlis et quoique si la
qualité c'est simplement la survie
naturel de cette élite
malgré toutes ces données deux points
inquiète les plus sceptiques
le premier le potentiel manque de recul
pour ces vaccins créée en l'espace d'un
an le recul qu'on a est quand même assez
extraordinaire
2 millions d'américains et plus de ces
sous les 100 milles en glenne on a deux
mois de recul
c'est un recul qui considéré par les
autorités sanitaires
si vous pouviez colle comme suffisant
mais sur le long terme
évidemment n'a pas la deuxième question
qui peut se poser est sur la technologie
utiliser les vaccins risers et moderna
sont à arn messager c'est la première
fois que cette méthode est commercialisé
pour les humains pour faire simple un
vaccin arn messagers contient le code de
fabrication des protéines servant à
combattre le coguic 19
ce code est alors communiquer au noyau
de nos cellules au contact du virus
notre corps identifiera les spikes
l'epic qui caractérise le coronavirus
nos cellules pourront alors fabriquer
elle même les protéines pour combattre
la maladie
à partir du code donné par le vaccin ce
technologie ne vient pas des derniers
mois huit de se passer elle correspond à
10 de travail sur la mise au point de la
rn6 le vaccin de pfizer a été autorisé
par l' agence européenne du médicament
et celui de modern art est en passe de
l'être
les effets secondaires sont toujours
scruté après vaccination
il faut attendre quinze minutes au
laboratoire pour s'assurer que vous
allez bien
[Musique]
e